hello dirt pile dirt pile pile of dirt
dirt I'm looking for some dirt have you
seen some dirt
it's about yay high looks like dirt
hello
dirt Hey someone took away this dirt
where'd all the dirt go huh I better
check with this dirt over here
hello dark have you seen some dirt it
looked pretty brown and was earthy kind
of like dirt goes by the name of Earth
if you've never heard of it before
also known as dirt - in the ground it
actually is the ground have you seen it
ground dirt really fine powdery dirt
have you seen it a dirt pile to the pile
well not really this time flat but it's
dirt have you seen it no well [ __ ] you
din hello
dirt pile dirt pile pile of dirt where's
the blacksmith Oh kill him Oh HSIP
way you chose who you know Snivy